of course there's the old saying I
forget who said it but I think it was
true in my life which is if at the age
of twenty-one you you're not a socialist
then you don't have any any heart and if
by the age thirty you still are and then
you don't have any brains so that was
kind of my experience I started out
young and idealistic and social justice
and fair distribution of resources and
and we were I didn't understand where
everybody couldn't be equally prosperous
and starting my own business was kind of
a wake-up call in a number of different
ways I had to I had to meet a payroll
every week and we had to satisfy
customers and we had competitors that
that we had to compete with in order to
have those customers come into our
stores and we had to compete with other
employers for our for our employees we
had to the wages were under competitive
pressures so there was all this
competition on us that that of course
made them operating the business
successfully difficult and it's kind of
like having to meet a payroll and having
to meet the demands of our customers is
a great destroyer of utopian fantasies
and utopian utopian ideologies you
you're in the real world and you have to
you have to meet the market test every
day and every week and I just found that
the belief system that I had going into
operating that business was was
inadequate to explain the experiences
that I was having in business and I
began to look around and read other
books and other philosophies to try to
make sense out of out of my life and out
of my business experience and it was
really through encountering the the free
market capitalist philosophies of
a Milton Friedman and and Friedrich
Hayek and Ludwig von Mises and and and
many other free-market philosophers that
I came to realize that this explanation
made a lot more sense in my business
experience and made more sense in terms
of how the world really operated and so
that's when my worldview began to shift
and I began to let go of being a sort of
a Democratic Socialist
any type of political ideology is going
to have a lot of different variants of
it a lot of different libertarians are
constantly arguing with each other who's
the most pure libertarian and who's most
ideologically pure I have no real
interest in those type of discussions or
arguments and what I resist in one of
the strains of libertarianism and I
reject I reject the idea that that
humankind is essentially selfish that
not only as an observation that we
frequently are selfish but there's a
strain of belief particularly in the in
the on Rand part of the movement that
believes people ought to be selfish that
that that's a virtue that humans are
always self-interested and and altruism
is evil and and love is is something
that makes us weak and so I reject that
aspect of loot libertarianism I'm I'm
I'm a caring compassionate person and I
believe that free markets and free minds
leads to the greatest human flourishing
so I really want humans to flourish and
I believe Liberty and market economies
and and capitalism and the best
strategies for full human flourishing so
I don't identify with that strain of
libertarianism that is sort of uncaring
and kind of a social Darwinian variant
of it I'm very uncomfortable with that
I'm not that way myself
I do believe that many libertarians are
animated by human flourishing
they-they-they we sincerely believe that
human flourishing that we need to be
free and that we need to be creative and
that through human freedom
entrepreneurship that humans are
creative they create new ways of of
creating value for each other that
expresses the self through the economic
system and leads to greater prosperity
not for a few but for for most people
and eventually all people so there is a
strain of deep idealism in the
libertarian movement it's again
sometimes masked over by that that
ideology of selfishness but the human
flourishing element is definitely a big
aspect of I think of the motivational
structure of many many libertarians
certainly it is for me
I think the zero-sum worldview is the
predominant one I think it's it's
something we've we've evolved with or
this idea that there's a limited fixed
PI and we have to distribute that PI in
an equal fair way that no one should get
unfair large pieces of that pie and if
someone is getting a bigger piece
necessarily someone else may be getting
a smaller piece since there's a finite
amount of pie to go around I also think
it comes from our our competitive sports
and that in competitive sports there's
there's a winner and there's a loser and
so we play games we play sports all our
lives so we come to believe that that in
the zero-sum world view that some are
winners and some are losers and in it
and then we can adjust society that
there should be no losers there should
be so we need to to to limit the pieces
of the pie anyone gets so that everyone
can have a fair and just piece of the
pie and I so I reject that I don't think
there is a necessarily a fixed pie the
beauty of capitalism and the beauty of
conscious capitalism is the realization
that the pie can grow that that through
voluntary exchange and through the value
creation that happens when the
stakeholders voluntarily cooperate and
voluntary exchange with each other is
that that the pie grows larger and so
there is more to distribute and that
distribution takes place through the
market through the market processes
through the exchange process as each as
each of the traders of course wants to
get a bigger piece from themselves and
competition sort of ultimately
determines the the percentages that each
of the different constituencies or
stakeholders gets in the exchanges but
that's a growing pie and it's a win win
win
in game and that turns me on
I'm very fired up and excited about that
because it means human flourishing isn't
trapped in some type of limited set of
constraints it means we can innovate and
create our ways out of any of these
traps any of these sort of I can't
remember or think of the phrase right
now I'm trying to I'm trying to recall
but this idea that we're in some type of
trap of limited resources and the only
limitations we have in the limitations
of human creativity human imagination
and intellectual capital that's been
accumulated as we continue to gain an
intellectual capital and as human
creativity is Unleashed and human
entrepreneurship is Unleashed then the
new the new innovations the new
creativity that expresses itself through
the marketplace through capitalism
allows us to solve problems that
previously were thought to be unsolvable
and human humans continue on the upward
spiral I mean a great example of this is
is people are very focused oftentimes on
the fact that there's still a billion
people on this planet that say live on
less than a dollar a day and that's a
and that certainly is a terrible tragedy
but if you put that in historical
context that's about 15% of the people
15 16 17 less than 20% of the people
alive on the planet live on less than a
dollar a day whereas 200 years ago 85%
of the people alive on the planet earth
lived on less than a dollar a day and
thus in today's dollars adjusted for
inflation so poverty has always been the
default condition of the human race
what's unprecedented is not poverty
what's unprecedented is wealth wealth
for not a few but prosperity for
literally billions of people every every
year now we see hundreds of millions of
people escape from poverty just in two
countries China and India it is the
greatest revolution in human prosperity
in all of human history it's all
occurred in the last 20 years and it's a
it's a fact that you almost never see
reported in the media instead we tend to
focus still on there on the remaining
people that are pas that are either too
poor and we're back on our zero-sum game
that somehow or another that's because
other people are greedy and selfish and
they're keeping these poor people down
rather than seeing poverty lesson
through capitalism and through
free-market expansion we tend to condemn
the very thing that's allowing people to
escape from poverty as the cause of the
poverty and it's ridiculous it's the
capitalism in and free markets or what's
going to allow us to escape from poverty
Muhammad Yunus likes to say that that by
the end of the 21st century poverty will
be something that we only see in museums
that it'll be something people look back
on and say gosh we used to have poor
people how is that even possible and I
do think that's the future of humanity
if we don't totally mess it up that we
are going to continue to learn we're
going to have our intellectual capital
spread we're gonna unleash the human
creativity because I do believe humans
have limitless creativity and we're
going to solve a lot of these problems
that are holding us back now and
humanity is going to continue to its
upward spiral and then we were going to
eliminate poverty I think there are
people alive today I perhaps will not
live to see the end of it but there are
pyeong people alive today that will
probably see the virtual end of poverty
in the human race in the 21st century
from a macro perspective
as capitalism is becoming conscious of
the framework that capitalism has to
exist and in order to in order to be
successful in order to flourish there's
certain key principles that that have to
be in place and we have to nurture those
principles or we won't have a
capitalistic order it's not something
that automatically exists and has to be
it has to have principles that's to be
grounded in those principles and some of
those principles include property rights
we have to have the right for people to
be able to own property at the same time
there needs to be the freedom to
exchange property we need to be able to
trade it we need to be able to create
something and then trade it or sell it
to someone else we need we need a rule
of law there needs to be laws that are
just and laws that are predictable and
laws that apply to everyone in the
society including the government a rule
of law is essentially you cannot have a
a capitalistic order without the rule of
law and whenever that comes into doubt
or if they're not stable property rights
you don't really have the the basis for
the capitalistic order and finally you
need a freedom to trade usually the
greater the the fewer restrictions on
the freedom to trade across the between
people but also between people in
different states people in different
countries the the greater value creation
that occurs so anytime you see a society
that's beginning to restrict the ability
to trade you see a society that is going
to lessen its prosperity it tends to
happen when people get preoccupied with
loss of jobs not understanding that you
may lose some jobs to a foreign country
if you allow freedom to trade but you're
gaining jobs became time you're gain
more net jobs because the people won't
give you their goods for free they want
to trade with you as well and so those
jobs
and goods that they want to trade for
the good and services they want that
will create greater employment at home
but that's very hard for the average
person to understand and so but anyway
conscious capitalism is understanding
these these basic core economic values
and becoming more conscious of them now
conscious business is is there are
certain principles behind that and one
principle is that business has a
potential for higher purpose that
maximizing profits if you ask people
what the purpose of business is they
usually say if you go to a cocktail
party and ask that question they'll
generally say well everybody knows that
the purpose of business is to maximize
profits it's to maximize shareholder
value and it's but that's a very odd
answer because that's not the answer we
would give if you asked what the purpose
of a doctor is need to heal the sick or
what the purpose of a teacher is to
educate people or what the purpose of
lawyer is or what the purpose of an
architect is or what the purpose of an
engineer is so so why is it that we
would come to this odd answer that the
purpose of business is to maximize
profits when I have known literally
hundreds of entrepreneurs in my life and
with very few exceptions very few of
them actually created their businesses
to try to maximize profits of course
they need to make money
but that's I need to eat in order to
live I need to breathe in order to live
I need my I need to create red blood
cells in order to live but that's not
the purpose of my life
to eat to breathe to create red blood
cells I have a much more transcendent
purpose in my life that gives my life
meaning and value to it business is no
different a business has the potential
for a higher and deeper purpose and
that's the first principle of conscious
business second principle is is that
there's a variety of stakeholders that
are interdependent that are connected
together customers employees
plyers investors communities both local
and larger communities and then the
larger environment that were part of
those are the most important
stakeholders there are other
stakeholders that are unlike an informal
wider circle such
is the government labor unions the media
activists of various cons but the idea
being that these stakeholders are
interdependent on one another and that
the conscious business attempts to
create value simultaneously for all of
these interdependent stakeholders that
it seeks the win-win-win business
strategy that may be a way to explain
that in a simple model version as a
retail business though which Whole Foods
is is that management's job is to help
our is to hire good people train them
well and help them to be happy and
fulfilled in their workplace and their
work and their jobs and then the team
members job is to satisfy our customers
help the customers to be happy in their
exchanges with the business so happy
team members leads to happy customers
and happy customers do more business
with the with the company and that leads
to happy investors so you have a
virtuous circle of happy team members
happy customers happy investors that
reflects and a simplified version this
idea of the interdependent nature of the
stakeholders and why you can't just
focus on creating value for the
investors alone because you must create
value for the team members who then
create value for the customers who then
create value for the investors so the
conscious business is recognized as this
is conscious of it and works to optimize
value for all of the key independent or
dependent stakeholders third principle
of the conscious business is what we
call conscious leadership or you might
also think of a servant leadership that
that the leaders of the organization
they're not there to line their pockets
and try to maximize their own personal
gain instead their job is to fulfill the
higher purpose of the business recognize
and fulfill the interdependent
stakeholder model and in a sense to
serve the organization
to sublimate their own ego and their own
ambitions for the good of the
organization and again it's not self
sacrificial or I'm not talking about
altruism I'm talking about recognizing
that in the long term they will also
gain the most through the flourishing of
the business and through flourishing of
all the stakeholders they too will
flourish that their identity is linked
and their own their own gain is linked
to the gain of all these other
stakeholders and then the fourth
principle is is that to realize these
first three principles you have to
create a culture a conscious culture
that has strategies structures and
processes that create a culture that
optimizes the stakeholder model fills
the purpose and allows the conscious
leadership to do their jobs so the
culture provides that background and the
processes and structures that the
conscious business needs in order to to
achieve its highest potential so when
you add those four principles together
you have a conscious business when you
add the conscious business with the key
principles of the conscious of the
conscious capitalism you truly have the
larger ecosystem of the conscious
capitalistic society one with conscious
businesses that are exchanging in a
consciously capitalistic way
you've just articulated what I call the
trade-off myth the belief that all this
sounds very good very idealistic but it
won't compete well in the marketplace
and when it runs up against a a business
that's not handicapped with this
idealism then it'll be in trouble
nothing could be further from the truth
it's the exact opposite that in fact the
conscious business has competitive
advantage when you work from a higher
purpose you you unleash greater degrees
of commitment greater degrees of loyalty
and greater creativity in the workplace
and that gives competitive advantage
when you work from the stakeholder model
you understand you're trying to optimize
the entire system you're able to do that
in such a way as when you optimize the
entire system you also optimize the the
value that you also you're creating for
the investors as well the business tends
to flourish at a higher level so in fact
the conscious business will win in most
instances all other things being equal
it will win in competition against less
conscious businesses and that's why I'm
confident that over the long term a
conscious capitalism they're going to
triumph it will I believe it will become
the new paradigm in the 21st century not
because it's it's more idealistic or
sounds better it'll become the dominant
paradigm simply because it will win it
will win in the marketplace and nothing
succeeds in capitalism more than success
itself so good ideas that work spread
and the competitive nature of the
marketplace is going to lead to these
competitions between conscious
businesses and less conscious businesses
and the conscious businesses all other
things being equal are going to win most
of those battles and so fairly quickly
meaning when I say quickly I mean 25 30
35 years we're going to see more and
more and more conscious businesses and
we'll make this shift towards conscious
cap
ballistic society
my first instinct is to tell you I do
think retail is one of the first areas
to shift possibly because they are
dealing with their customers on a
day-to-day basis and they've got their
more labor-intensive as well they tend
to hire and employ more people like
Whole Foods Market employs 57,000 people
so we're and we have millions of
customers so in a sense and we're in an
extremely competitive marketplace food
retailing and we don't have any patents
we don't have any in the government's
not protecting us in some way from
competition so and we have formally
competitors are much larger than and
then I so like Walmart Kroger Safeway
companies like that so retail is one of
the first areas to ship some many of the
conscious businesses that I know tend to
be either retailers or service
businesses companies like The Container
Store or Costco or Starbucks or the
Southwest Airlines the these are our
businesses that Trader Joe's these are
businesses that our retailers are
service oriented so I do think maybe the
conscious conscious business revolution
and conscious capitalism revolution will
see that take hold in a more large-scale
way in the retail and service first I
can predict also possibly what will be
last
I predict possibly wall street will be
last or the pure financial part of our
economy which to a greater extent its
stake it doesn't have as much of a
stakeholder model it does tend to be
dominated by the the profit for profit
maximization model and shareholder
return model to a greater degree than
other segments of our society so I
suspect retail and services will be
first the financial sector will be last
I do think that the economy is going to
continue to evolve towards more service
the human beings are doing more things
to serve one another in terms of
services but there new things are if you
think about the whole technology area so
much of that didn't even exist 10-15
years ago that there was no Facebook
there was no Google there was no iPods
there were no iPhones really
BlackBerry's didn't even exist 15 years
ago so so many different things changed
so rapidly and new industries and whole
industries can be created fairly fairly
quickly I think it's safe to say that
we're going to see greater innovations
in education that here's an area that
needs radical innovation that we don't
allow competition
we don't allow we haven't unleashed
human creativity so education
potentially if we could unmanned applies
education and truly allow entrepreneurs
to get going on that I can't think of
hardly health care and education are the
two most regulated areas in our society
and they're also the ones that are most
or least satisfactory to people those
are areas that we need to 2d monopolize
and allow more competition to occur so
those are two huge areas education and
health care are both service areas so
that those are growth industries I also
think all types of leisure travel is a
is a as a society becomes more affluent
its its desire to travel increases and
to explore that the younger generation
today people that are in their 20s for
example they have travelled so much more
than my generation had I mean for me a
big deal when I was in my 20s and going
down to Mexico and that was like the
foreign country or maybe you get up to
Canada but today people haven't just
gone to Europe
but they've gone all over the world by
the time they're 30 years old if they're
young and well-educated they world
travel is going to be continued to be
its goal in particular as globalization
continues to occur we're going to
continue to explore also think huge huge
possibilities in entertainment I mean
look how much entertainment has evolved
and shifted in a sense something like
big think it's education it's
entertainment
it's and it's a synthesis of those two
and it's probably got lots of other
things in it as well that I haven't just
picked up yet
I do see lots more creativity lots more
innovations lots more entrepreneurship
around around entertainment and humans
educating one another entertaining one
another serving one another new ways for
humans to enjoy life new ways for humans
to learn and grow we are going to
continually try to figure out ways to
serve ourselves better and it's it's
amazing how even think about something
like Pilates we didn't exist in any kind
of scale 25 years ago yoga existed but
hardly anybody did it now you see those
are our activities that are also leading
to greater human flourishing through
helping humans to be more fit and
stronger more flexible so it's
fascinating watching the world and
watching humans evolve and watching our
society evolve it's I love it I'm so
glad to be part of it and to have
contributed a little bit to it myself
you